hi my name is Jim bagel I'm one of the
owners of grapery along with Jack pandal
and today we're in a cotton candy
vineyard were involved in a breeding
program where we breed new grape
varieties it's all-natural non-gmo and
we've been able to come up with some
really great flavors and grapes one of
the first ones is cotton candy but we
have many more to come you know just to
see people eating healthy and enjoy and
eating healthy it's really motivates us
cotton candy grapes never heard of such
a thing
I don't know how a grape could taste
like cotton candy the fact that you told
me this grape is gonna taste like candy
creeps me out
they smell like normal grapes here we go
well oh I shall win whoa I'm tastes like
cotton candy oh my god oh my goodness I
can taste Wow I feel like I'm at the
ballpark or the old carnival if I burped
in someone's face right now they'd be
like dude you've been eating cotton
candy it's like a flavor tripping type
of thing you're expecting one thing but
then you get something that's slightly
different now I don't know if I know
what cotton candy tastes like anymore
it's like what you wish mean your kid
like I wish this salad in my mouth
tasted like a pizza I think these will
be great for kids because it will
encourage them to eat fruit because it's
fruit that tastes like candy Society
teaches the kids that vegetables and
fruit is gross but like it tastes so
good fruits and vegetables are delicious
if you're gonna breed candy into fruit
I'm in love with you
I don't think I would want my wine to
taste like cotton candy that certainly
not